now you two I know have worked together
at least once before on the football
film The Express about five years ago I
don't know how far back you go if it's
further than that but what happens when
the two of you get on his set
considering your two people who have
been working very steadily for for a
good amount of time do you kind of
immediately start reminiscing about
people that you know and and other
experiences you've had together well you
left out one other credit that we have
yes I play dumb he plays mr. Krabs on
SpongeBob SquarePants and I was had the
golden opportunity of playing mr. Krabs
grandfather so we had that that's
including credit I was very skeptical
that any farm film could be made that
was going to be honest about how its
evolved over the years but you know from
the opening credits or from from the
opening of this movie with that montage
you know it's it's all a microcosm of
how it's all evolved from people getting
their hands dirty two people sitting in
there in the cabs not even steering
thinking whatever thoughts they think in
which Dennis did so great you know this
sort of how we've moved away from the
from the earth literally how our food
has become has become not such not a
product of human labor anymore in
Barrani and seeing his films before Chop
Shop goodbye solo and man push cart and
he has a very different point of view of
of America and he's a master of his
subject he spent about a year out in
Iowa living with people going up
knocking on their doors people like
George nailer and really getting to know
his subject and and you know what he
found is that they these people are
they're not yokels they're really
sophisticated businessmen who step out
there backdoors into a multi-million
operation basically Wall Street has come
to the Midwest and the only thing
missing of the skyscrapers but then
remain he's never made a movie with a
movie star in it or even actors really
except for red and goodbye solo that one
and read read plays your dad there and
he was in him one of other one of her
means other films and so it's a you know
it's a real adventure for four remain as
well but he couldn't had a better lead I
think and I thought he put together
pretty darn good Cass I think I think
zach is terrific as well so you know it
he made it happen and you don't you
don't pass up the opportunity to work
with a tour rameen and I did talk a lot
about Willy Loman in Death of a Salesman
before we we did this because that was
his way as I you know I was talking
about Wall Street coming to the Midwest
before but that's not that's not really
a story and he needed a way into a human
story with us he didn't want to make a
movie with an agenda that would preach I
you and Willy Loman was a you know
someone who was chasing the American
dream so desperately wanted to be number
one in the eyes of his kids and his
family and also himself but yet he had
corrupted him cell phone on in the
process of doing that and it presents
this bravado to the world Henry Whipple
does that you know confidence of success
but the cracks start to occur I mean is
you hope you can see in the film and it
comes to much too for him to bear